lebanon is a country numb
with grief this is the family of sahar
faris
she was one of the first emergency
responders a paramedic
in a team of ten firefighters
this group photograph was taken just as
her unit responded to the fire at the
port
they didn't know what they were heading
towards a blast as powerful
as an earthquake this is the hunger that
has exploded they first were here in
their truck
and the fire was taking place here in
this hangar
she ran from she was here and
she tried to get it yeah she tried to
get to safety
she just reached here this point and
this is where her body was found
yeah we found her body here under 15
centimeters of
sand sahar is not gonna
come back and live with us and be with
us again
although i i really hope that at least i
could see her one last time so i can hug
her
and and say goodbye because i couldn't
i didn't see her her extended family
have been gathering throughout the week
to mourn
and pay their respects to a young life
cut short by a disaster
which they say was caused by a corrupt
and callous government
she was betrayed killed her
they killed her jeans they killed her
future
you mean it's like it's like when does
does any father
send his sons to to to die to death
i mean i mean she's working for for for
the country
she's working for for for for for this
nation
at the ports where the thousands of tons
of ammonium nitrates were negligently
stored before they exploded the search
is continuing
most of the firefighting team sahar was
with along with many others are still
missing
for the lebanese emergency responders
this is now
a very personal mission sniffer dogs
from
international rescue teams are tracking
across the scorched earth
but no one here expects to find anyone
alive
the extent of the damage is really
overwhelming this was the center of the
explosion it used to be the port
but now it's a 40 meter crater filled
with sea water
and over here is beirut's skyline
totally devastated it really is hard to
process just how destructive this
explosion has been
and it's also hard to think when you
look at this how this port will ever be
functional again
lebanon's three days of official
mourning
may be over but the suffering does not
stop
for sahar's family they want an
international investigation
into what they've called a crime against
humanity
but they say in a country like theirs
they'll probably never know the truth
or get justice alex rossi
sky news beirut
you